I feel like there's certain types of
people that's that's thrive in
quarantine I just feel like you're one
of those kind of because I think you
have a lot of dad in you I get a lot of
work done yeah but you know how dad was
an isolator almost and he came out doing
things on his own and he was okay being
by himself
I not only that dad was frugal in a way
that I am yeah when I went to visit them
in Chandler Arizona when they had shop
off of Amla school I remember it was
like before me her and I went to he
lived in this little crappy apartment
and I walked in there and there is
literally a mattress just one mattress
on the ground one razor a hot plate like
he had nothing and I'm like oh I'm like
that yeah I think mom like mom is more
like you are in that sense yeah you know
you guys like to decorate you know get
the nice things you just need the basic
survival needs or whatever
do you miss yeah I do I do a lot I do
that song cause I didn't want to put dad
you know I know that he was abusive and
everything and he was but we have to
take into account that like for the
other half of his life he was he chilled
out you know what I mean yeah he wasn't
always like you know I'm saying like
yeah that guy I mean from maybe from the
70s until 1990 whenever whenever we
graduated but um yeah yeah I think that
I was I was in so much pain I didn't
know what to do like I didn't want to
relapse yeah I'm like I just wanted to
write and I know look I didn't my
intention wasn't to do EP it was just to
write yeah so I wrote and then I just
made a try I was just messing with my
sampler do you guys really like the song
no no I love the song yeah I really do
love the song I thought the video was
really touching and and um I
you know I struggle with it I you know
there are times where I miss him
incredibly and I can't believe he's gone
there are not yeah yeah but she's you
know what Steve because I I I talk to
her almost like every day or every other
day
yeah she's experiencing something maybe
that's similar to my mom and my sisters
felt when my dad died which was we
obviously meant dearly but there's a
sense of like deep relief and freedom
like from from you know because for my
mom it was taking care of like a sick
man for for a very long time and then
being kind of you know not change but
that's your obligation and your whole
world is just revolving under that so
you put away your own life and your own
everything right to take somebody and
there is a sense of deep deep like
sadness yeah like what other what what I
think that we all have like we we are
ashamed to say also is that even for me
like when my dad died I felt like
relieved and like I could live again but
I don't know I can't speak for your mom
but that's the sense that I get from her
because like she'll Ted doesn't she text
you a lot and she's like I've had a
great day I went for a while every day
so she's liberated in a way like before
she was just I think when you and I you
and I were so far removed from dad's
illness because he lived in Arizona we
would visit them once or twice a year
for six months I know I remember he's
out there like that's why it's like I
was there you know when he was doing
physical therapy and physical it was
really hard to watch him because in his
mind because he was so stubborn like I
remember one time he was he was staying
at one of those places I went Aetna that
the night shift yeah he was you know and
and then so like I helped him up out of
you know and then I brought me into the
bathroom it was one of those handicapped
bathrooms with the handle the bars and
so I was watching a boxing in the other
room and I'm
I'm like dude he's been in there for
20-25 minutes so I knocked on the door
and then I opened it and he was
literally trying to do dips oh sure he
was he was he lied he was trying to
exercise it's like that's one thing my
dad had he was like you know he he did
it he couldn't accept the fact that he
couldn't walk and you know I'm saying
and he never he never got to the point
where he was okay with that yeah he was
like he was more like I'm gonna show you
no no I'm different members yeah yeah
yeah you mean later
yeah you just fighter fighting mentality
yeah yeah it's difficult man yeah I I
miss him incredibly and um you know this
has been for everyone just a weird time
it's you know for me specifically it's
been a shocking a year of you know dad
dying relapsing and then this quarantine
it's just been really kind of crazy yeah
and there's been great things as well
you know so um you know but you know I
honestly I've been thinking about you a
lot and I just want you to I know that
you you're thinking that you're strong
as an ox
and I know that but I just I worry that
I don't want you to go out and think
that you can beat I just don't want you
to catch this thing